[Música]
hace 10 años justo antes de que se
legalizara el matrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo en Francia conocimos a
tima y a sus dos madres
en aquella época Anabelle y valeji solo
esperaban la llegada del gran día
Si pudiera me casaría contigo ahora
mismo
es conmovedor volvernos a ver 10 años
después hemos cambiado mucho físicamente
solo un poco
nuestro cabello está más blanco el
pequeñito ha crecido pasar de los cuatro
años a los 14 No es cualquier cosa
me doy cuenta de que soy muy importante
[Risas]
y eso es reconfortante
[Música]
el 21 de septiembre de 2013 y Anabelle
se dieron el sí acompañadas de sus
familiares y amigos
[Música]
somos como todos Ahora me siento parte
de la sociedad y no fuera de ella con
los mismos derechos que los demás
durante meses el proyecto de ley dividió
profundamente a Francia
por un lado hubo manifestaciones a favor
[Música]
y por el otro en contra
en el parlamento el debate político
también era intenso
cristianto viejá ministra de justicia en
aquella época se mantuvo firme la ley
Fue adoptada
una gran Victoria para didier Y Gael
a quienes conocimos hace 10 años esto es
adentro con la poca gente que había
el registro familiar la culminación
lucharon por la aprobación de esta ley
no solo se manifestaron sino que
participaron en su elaboración incluso
Fueron escuchados por el comité
legislativo
cuando se celebró la boda fue el punto
álgido pero también el punto final
no firmado y sellado hicimos todo lo que
teníamos que hacer nos habían reconocido
éramos legítimos somos una familia
mírennos como una familia hace 10 años
acababan de acoger a alguien su hogar un
pequeño de cuatro años que Gael había
adoptado en Haití en ese entonces diría
no tenía derechos parentales sobre su
hijo tras casarse pudo adoptarlo Y ser
reconocido como su padre
si algo le llegaba pasará al vivo a mi
cónyuge
habría habido problemas de herencia
habría perdido la custodia de mi hijo al
menos lo mismo que si necesitaba ser
hospitalizado lejos de casa sin la
autorización de Gael no era posible para
mí eso era lo peor los riesgos los
corría mi hijo Gael y didier se sienten
Afortunados en su pueblo en las afueras
de León siempre se han sentido aceptados
Así que cuando en todo el país empezaron
a organizarse las manifestaciones contra
el matrimonio entre personas del mismo
sexo fue un shock
no pensamos que pudiera haber una parte
de la población que se movilizara hasta
el punto de querer obstaculizar una ley
como esa que había sido aprobada muy
fácilmente en los demás países de Europa
vaya uno a saber por qué en Francia se
armó talio
estábamos bastante impactados por lo que
estaba ocurriendo y por las palabras que
se utilizaban eran hirientes eran
estigmatizantes
ahora 10 años después sentimos como si
hubiera sido hace 30 años porque ahora
es bastante normal para todo el mundo
para quedar embarazada de tima Anabel
fue a Bélgica en Francia hace 10 años la
reproducción asistida no estaba
autorizada para las parejas homosexuales
ni para las mujeres solteras
al igual que diria la pareja de Anabelle
solo pudo adoptar a tima hasta después
de haberse casado
tema es muy consciente de las luchas que
hubo en torno al matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo pero no es algo
en lo que insistamos todos los días
y para él su vida normal es vivir con
dos mamás que están casadas tienen
nuestros dos apellidos esa es su vida
no tengo amigos que estén en mi misma
situación pero lo aceptan
no les importa no cambia nada es como si
tuviera un papá y una mamá
Solo que tengo dos mamás y no tengo papá
pero a mi alrededor tengo figuras
paternas Amigos
íntimos de mis mamás tíos mis abuelos
hoy 10 años después la sociedad francesa
ha cambiado pero Anabel y valergie
prefieren pensar en el futuro con
cautela
somos conscientes de que tenemos un
estatus que nos pueden quitar
rápidamente
hay que mantenerse alerta Exacto hay que
permanecer alerta los derechos se pueden
obtener pero también se pueden quitar
la aceptación va en aumento tenemos tres
ministros abiertamente homosexuales hace
10 años eso era imposible sentimos que
las cosas están mejorando pero sentimos
que todavía hay críticas que generan
mucho odio
que están escondidas entre las sombras y
que están listas para emerger
eso no lo hemos olvidado vivimos con eso
aún así tenemos que estar alerta Aunque
hoy estemos a salvo estamos casi seguros
de que no habrá vuelta atrás
no creo que pueda haber vuelta atrás
estás preocupado
a corto plazo no me preocupa pero no
creo que sea algo que no pueda pasar
nunca
hay que permanecer alerta
[Música]